welcome back to on base with Mookie
Betts live in your Bleacher Report app I
am here today with one of my favorite
people in the world
JD Martinez what's going on brother how
you doing nothing man just happy to be
here I'm happy you're here too because
it's really been
a long time I've been trying to get you
on this show
for a long time and we had it scheduled
and then you know some life happened
right got hurt you had to get a backy
out of me yep you know what I'm saying
and uh I got out yep back went out got
the backyard I mean now we're back
and uh I'm glad to have you on the show
Lisa better late than never right hey
man I'm glad to be here I'm glad I could
finally make it exactly last series of
the year last series of the year last
year's year so uh I want to go give you
run down some of your accolades a little
bit
um you got six All-Stars
three silver Sluggers
two in one year and 18. I don't know how
that happened we'll we'll get to that
but we'll talk about that and you've won
a World Series hopefully
we can win another one Amen to that and
so that that's a a very decorated uh
career so far and you got started a
little late which we'll talk about some
more uh later but I did want the viewers
to uh know your accolades so the show is
called on base off base
um and we play a game I mean the show is
called home base I'm sorry we play a
game called on base off base in or out
right and so the first one
do you understand the game all right I
understand it you understand the game
all right so I'm with it I'm on base on
base if you're not with it I'm off base
off base all right all right hit me with
it emotional support alligators out
don't you gotta say anything else why
alligator that's an alligator
I'm from Florida but you don't mess with
alligators okay so when you're fishing
you're a fisherman what do you do when
you see the gator I fish in the ocean
the Gators are in the freshwater they're
in Everglades so you don't you don't go
back there because of the Gators yeah
I'm out but they got snakes
they got Gators
I don't even know they got all kinds of
names but the ocean don't go I just
worry about sharks the ocean doesn't
have anything scary sharks okay that's
about it and but you're not getting the
water no way so it don't matter yeah
it is kind of you know
gotta look around every time you just
don't jump in you know especially out of
marinas because you can see a little bit
Yeah you can see a little bit I mean
sometimes you'll see them down there
sometimes you won't that's a scary point
no no I'm not doing that okay did you
see that they were in the the at the
Phillies game someone tried to get into
the park with an emotional alligator for
real yeah
what yeah I don't even know how do you
even get that who trained the Navigator
how does that even I don't know there's
a lot of questions that's real life yeah
at the Phillies game look it up look it
up I think it was I mean shout out to
them for trying it you know but wow
all right so
two let's go the best you play Mario
Kart
yeah when I was a kid yeah okay so the
best Mario do you remember the courses
I know rainbow road that was it that
wasn't the hardest one that was the
that's like the one fourth one yeah he's
just trying to finish lasting that one
all right so the best Mario Kart course
has Dodger Stadium featured in it
on base or off base on that
unless I believe it no are you on or off
or are you on it you're on that yeah you
said rainbow you know what I'm saying oh
no I see it that's dope that's cool I
think that's super cool yeah that's cool
that's like the newer upgrade of Mario
yeah they didn't they didn't have this
you know that ain't the one we came up
with no like they're flying and stuff
like that yeah yeah yeah you didn't
really have that many options on the
power-ups you know what I'm saying you
would fall off and a little Cloud would
come and pick you up yeah put you back
on the map so sorry that's cool that's
neat that's really really neat
um
you remember playing uh Mario Kart with
Cy Chris Young no I never played
Christian I've never played with Cy so
in Cleveland you know in Cleveland they
have the the uh arcade game yep and Cy
Cy is like a you know if you know Cy
he's like one of those people that just
loves games it could be tic-tac-toe it
could be Checkers it could be Mario Kart
whatever that's what Cy that's that's
what he's really good at yeah and I
think he's
running the clubhouse really it hey I
hurt me to say it too it hurts me to say
that because I hate admitting that he's
good at stuff
but yeah so uh Mario
um I didn't know if you had played with
him or not but not neither play with Cy
who did you play with it reminds me of
Ian Kinsler Ian Kinsler and that he used
to play um knockout on that little same
arcade oh yeah okay yeah he'd always be
up against Tyson knocking him out every
single time I said how do you do it he's
like one of those guys kind of like you
annoying kind of always good at
everything you know sorry to be annoying
I know
engagement foosball though you did we
had every rematch on that okay so if you
weren't in the MLB you'd be an F1 driver
oh
hell yeah so what is it about driving
that you like
man I don't know I got into the F1 thing
back with the that drive to survive
documentary on Netflix okay
I don't know it's just
I don't know how to explain it it's just
is this a cool yeah it's just a cool
thing it's a lot of adrenaline fast cars
have you rode in one before nah that
would be sick I never wrote a one I've
been to a couple races been a couple are
you going to the one there's one in
Vegas I'm trying to I want to go I got
to plan it you know it's hard to get
there yeah that's a hard one that's a
hard ticket right now it's probably
expensive yeah and it's a hard ticket
I'm gonna try to go I've been to two in
Austin already
they opened that one up in Miami but
it's during the season yeah can't do
that one so in about three years I'll be
going to that one
well we got to get you somewhere
accurate before that and then um yeah
man I just want to go to that Vegas one
that'll be dope dope all right
so we'll see uh if anyone out there can
help JD get to the Vegas F1 race uh you
can find him hit me up
at Dodger Stadium and uh you can come
holler at them or on Instagram
uh okay so last question
you are always the last one on the team
bus yeah
what
why why you know what I'm saying like
what you know what I I mean yeah why
let's go there's this thing called Cuban
time Cuban time okay you know so like
oh it was like about like 15 minutes
late why has it got to be 15. why why I
don't know two or three what was two or
three too close to one time yeah I don't
know it's just like you know if the bus
is at two yep
you should set your alarm for like 12 45
okay but what do you say then you're
gonna snooze it one time oh you're me
because I'm asleep I like to sleep okay
so 12 45 you hit no no I'm sorry sorry
if the bus is at 2 12 45. yeah so at 12
45 no that's what you should do you hit
but you said you hit snooze yeah you
snooze at 12 45 I'm out the day is done
not our day our day knows our day's just
starting
you know very valid but 1240 no you
don't have kids yeah kids you don't have
kids but then I'm like for me
I push it back you know push it back one
you know so then I gotta wake up
get some breakfast at one take a shower
breakfast at one yeah breakfast at one
so you think you think that waking up at
12 45 you're supposed to wake up at 12
45 then hit snooze yeah then wake up eat
breakfast
at one o'clock
and then take a shower get yourself
together and you think that you can do
all this in an hour yeah never could do
it but my brain says I can and so after
all the times you've tried and failed
you still didn't want to make the
adjustment no I just say you know what
if I missed the bus I'll take a Uber
it's all good you know that's the way my
brain works
so you so so you schedule
to get on the bus at two o'clock yeah
and say if you miss it you miss it if I
miss it I miss it I'm good with it
right now I live my life that way
if you miss it yeah if I miss it I miss
it man Life's too short I want to enjoy
every moment I have dude so enjoy it
rest not I can't live with that stress
of like I gotta be somewhere I gotta do
this I gotta do that the only place I
gotta be on time too is the batter's box
and you'll be late there too no no I've
never been late to the batter's box yeah
you did just the last week yeah yeah
I've been late last week you just got
this you end up hitting a double first
pitch you got in there and relax no
that's a
clock on me and got me this year got you
gotcha you late to the batter's box now
you laid everywhere I guess I am
I guess I am man and it's just because
you want to you want to enjoy
life in your moment so
let me use the batter's box though
that's you know you don't want to be
like that I don't want to be late to
that I don't know how so you're like you
the bust the tube if I miss it I miss it
so I'm just gonna enjoy
chilling at the house yeah I'm just
gonna you know
you can't wake up and be like oh crap I
gotta go I gotta go you know start my
day off all crazy so but if that happens
eight years you're screwed for us today
no if it happens it's just it happens oh
you know what you're not screwed because
you're just gonna be late for everything
for us today because you got to get
yourself got it makes sense you know
makes perfect sense all right so last
week your player of the week
very good to watch very good to see very
good for you
because you know obviously we're home
boys and when you ball them like this I
feel like I'm balling
I feel like Mutual yeah I'm saying and
so
um what do you think I ain't gonna say
what clicked but
sure I'm gonna say it what clicked
man I don't know I think we just we put
my hands lower that's it that's it
starting my hands a little lower I was
up here
brought them down to here
and it's been great yeah and it's been
going good so far you know uh
just gotta ride it you know it is I mean
you're the one that taught me about the
waves right yeah and so
I I kind of use life with this analogy
as well it's like in for those who
obviously don't know
it's when you told me like Surfers
talking about the Surfers and how they
swim out right and they'll be there all
day trying to catch waves
and
the surfer that
you know you never really catch good
waves if you're trying to get on a wave
and then as soon as that one
kind of gets a little rocky or whatever
then jumping through another way and
jump to another wave yep that's not
really surfing it's like you get on one
wave just ride it just ride it until it
runs out until it runs out and then you
swim back out and get another one so
um
I mean it's kind of like what we talked
about back in back when we were talking
about that was like
can always be
looking at that other way of being like
dang that's a better wave I want to go
on that one you know what if I fix this
what if I do that and I can just
keep going well what do you know how do
you know this wave ain't gonna last for
a mile you know for months it could go
it could go for forever yeah and then
before you know it you had one wave all
year you wrote it all year and but you
would never know because you try to jump
on four or five waves now it's been four
months you don't you haven't even gotten
on a wave exactly because you're out
there searching for the perfect wave
instead of riding the one that's given
to you yep speaking of riding waves
that man in Atlanta has been on a wave
and it is
unbelievable 40 70. that's a joke I want
to acknowledge that I know uh
some people may not have been too
excited about them stopping the game
like because they end up stopping the
game and getting the Ovation whatever
um to me I think uh it was definitely
needed the game needed to be 100
doing that like that's never it's never
been done it's never been done yeah
that's never been that's that's stopping
the game worthy that is stopping the
game worthy yeah
you know what I'm saying and so when you
when you watched him up close when you
watch him
what it what is it that kind of stands
out to you the most man when I saw him
at the All-Star Game
he wasn't a big dude he doesn't look
like this big guy you know you walk
around and you see all these guys you
see you know Olsen and yeah all these
huge guys just he doesn't he's not that
big but then when you see him in the Box
he seems like he's huge yeah he's he's
he's sneaky he's bigger than you think
he is but he's not that he's not a big
guy and then he hits the ball and you're
like that's different that's different
when it comes off yeah when it comes off
his back you're like that's different
it's so loud and so fast it's so Twitchy
it's a one if I had to give him one word
that I would describe him with his
twitch yeah he's got that he's got that
just that way just running swinging
throwing everything everything he's got
that twitching that's what you need to
really
um shoot do that you know it was I mean
that boy hit it and it gets 120 120 come
on bro come on bro I know the cameras
caught me making the face and I would
make that face every single time the
whole Dugout did oh yeah I think yeah
y'all just caught me it was everybody
that did that I thought it was a
technicality on the on the on the big
screen when it said 121 I said what yeah
that ain't right no I said let me go
look at the iPad and it said 121.2 I
said oh my God yes that's unbelievable
um all right so let's get to JD let's
get back to JD
so we're going to start about your
journey
um your dad immigrated here and
from Cuba
you grew up in Miami
and so
uh how's your Spanish by the way
so it's Sub sub yeah so I would say like
I get my point across you know okay you
guys understand me my Spanish is pretty
good like pretty good just to get it
across yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like I
can I can have a community I can have
communication with people I can talk to
people I can
you could throw me in Cuba right now and
I'll be fine okay okay you know but
you would be amongst the worst of the
English there I mean yeah English for
Spanish it's just you know past and
present tense and pronunciations about
butcher okay okay so
uh pops immigrated over here but your
your granddad he uh built
did he build a stadium or tell me about
that yeah so my grandfather was a
he was like the governor the the mayor
he was the mayor of a city and a
comatantas somebody that I was born
where he was born in
he was the mayor of that City and he was
the first
government official to put lights on a
baseball field so they didn't have
lights on the stadiums before
so he actually put the lights on it so
like when I was in Miami and I would
always come around
um Paul Casanova you know plus his heart
was my mentor passed away in 2017.
when he first found out who my dad was
he's like wow you're
that means you're
the son of my grandfather okay and he's
like man I was like yeah how do you know
him he goes are you kidding me everybody
knows angelio Julio he goes he put
the first um lights the first lights in
Cuba oh that's cool yeah so it was like
he's
known all around all the Cuban guys know
around about them oh so old OG Cubans so
if you went back they'd be like oh and
they probably don't know me okay come on
third generation
yeah it's way too far okay all right so
you got into baseball I've been playing
baseball your whole life you playing
other sports
I played football in high school and I
played basketball
I was terrible at basketball yeah I mean
you got Cuban I scored I played a whole
scene that has nothing to do with Cuban
people I guess it does but I don't mean
that in a bad way like I just you know
okay so basketball and you play football
what position you playing for
quarterback and defensive end
you went from QB to defensive end I was
playing both sides which one were you
good at QB I was trash at the end really
yeah they were just they were at I never
forget they were intimidated by me that
um
first couple games they're like oh
there's a big guy
six foot two same size like a buck 70
probably 50 pounds 60 pounds lighter
halftime comes around coach goes JD
you're doing a great job over there man
you're killing it they're not even
running the ball over there this and
that we're stopping them second half
they said let's go test out the skinny
guy ah that was the last time I played
defensive end
did you have to make what happened like
you had to start hitting people nah man
they
send the full back over to block me I
was just getting annihilated bro every
play it was I was just me trying to
tackle the running back and getting lit
up by the fullback or lineman or Lyman
or whatever and I was like
all right coach we're going back to QB
okay so did you have any offers or
anything playing Cupid no no no so
I played my sophomore year right and I
played for fun oh you're playing
football yeah I was playing for fun I
mean the coach because we used to play
like flag football and PE and the coach
was like he's got a good arm okay like
would you want to be quarterback and I
was like Mom let me play that means
y'all were not good
no we were we were pretty good yeah so
he he picked you up just from PE for JV
this is JV because I'm the JV team okay
JV yeah okay got it I thought we had
like a stud quarterback in Varsity okay
yeah and he was a senior oh yeah okay so
JVC so you you you was you was getting
lit up in JV oh yeah oh man that means
you were nothing 10th grade Doug what's
your name oh man
I threw a pass one time I had the the
set the what is it called uh
you ain't got to talk about no more
because you're talking about JV dog
you know what I'm saying we talking
about hey jv's for real man don't get it
twisted there were some big boys down
there
they hidden
we're not talking about James
okay so we play baseball and I got lit
up one time I said this football thing
ain't for me all right we're going back
to baseball back to baseball
you got drafted you originally got
drafted by the twins yep and you said no
when did what when did you get when did
you get drafted I didn't even know I got
drafted by the twins I was in high
school
um I didn't even know I was in the keys
on the boat
chilling at The Sandbar and my boy Chris
goes JD you know you got drafted I said
what so nobody was talking to you or
anything nah
36 round there's 50 rounds back then
this is like but they didn't even so you
you just got picked up had no idea you
had no idea I said I did they said yeah
you got drafted by the twins the 36th
round I said word I said all right I
didn't have any college offers any
anywhere to go at the time
we just want States state championship
game back to back in 6A in Florida which
is like a big deal everyone knew where
they were going I had no idea no offers
nothing so
twins called and they said hey we want
you to be a draft and follow and if you
remember what that is yeah and um
pretty much the team has your rights for
a year after they draft you so I was
like all right cool what do I got to do
it's like oh we want to we want you to
play in a community college so that we
if we like you we'll sign you the next
year
I said all right cool
Well Community College
they said
let me see if I can get you into one all
right I said all right do what you got
to do yep so
my man Eric Cruz
who was the High School infield coach
he said JD what are you doing this week
and I said nothing chilling he goes all
right get in my car we're going all up
and down Florida to making doing tryouts
for every community college team there
is and so I he had gotten this from the
Twins then yeah because the twins have
called and this and that and so he's
like I'm like all right let's do it we
did like eight tryouts in like three
days my arm was hanging I couldn't even
throw the ball exactly throw home and do
all this stuff you know
nobody jumped not one not one Community
College oh my goodness okay so then
go another couple weeks and
there was a tryout at Nova Southeastern
University which was right on the road
for me it's a division two school and
they're like hey um you want to go try
out for them I said yeah let's go
you're about to be done yeah it's done
I said all right let's go so then I go I
do the tryout they said hey um yeah
we'll give you 1500 for your for your
tuition I said
1500 I said the tuition is 23 Grand
I said he said yeah that's all we got I
said Dad I said
they offered me 1500 he said go we'll
figure it out luckily I had good grades
so I had this thing called Bright
Futures which is like Florida covers
like a certain percentage or whatever so
it kind of cut cut down like I think it
was like 16 or 17 or whatever and then
we just you know my dad my dad figured
out the rest I don't know you know and
so you go there so how was how was your
experience there it was good I didn't
start my freshman year
and then my coach gets this um
gets pissed off with the team because a
lot of kids they were just like you know
mad about like not playing and thought
they were better this coach is like if
anyone has a problem
come to my office and I'll tell you
what's what I said all right oh you
went to the dog yeah I went I said it
was my freshman year you know me I got
no hair in my time walked right up in
there
I said man this kid I'm faster I throw
better I hit harder where's he better
because he's a senior
that's it because I had a feeling you
would be in here
band played every day after that yeah
and then you and that was it and then
you end up getting drafted again and I
got drafted
um in the 20th round
I'm supposed to go in the you know top
10 Rounds
and didn't happen I remember being my
I remember my family had um my mom and
my dad had this whole like um
you know like dinner thing you know
Cuban people like to celebrate
everything okay so they know it's like
oh we got an excuse to party we're doing
it okay I know Jay's supposed to get
drafted so
I have everyone over there supposed to
go on the first day don't go on the
first day I get pissed I'm like so they
had decorations yeah decorations
everything you know this and that it was
kind of embarrassing you know a little
bit Yeah so get in my car this is
actually a really funny story by the way
get in my car
I I leave the party everyone's like
where's JD this and that so now it's
like day two or whatever
day two and they're like hey we're gonna
have it we're gonna have everybody back
at the house
you know you're gonna get drafted today
this is still there's still something to
be proud of this and that I was like
whatever dude my I felt bad for my
parents I don't want to be there because
yeah you know so I go there
draft hits this and that now we're
around 10 11
12. no JD's been out on the board 13 14.
I get in my car I leave again I leave
again I shoot a text out
to
the Royals the Astros the Braves
and the Blue Jays because those are the
ones that did like you know pre
pre-workout stuff for them I said please
give me a chance draft me I'm gonna make
it to the major leagues I won't let you
down
right
nobody responded the only one that
responded was
the Royals said I wish I had more
influence I believe you this and that
but it's out of my hands and then the
Astros called
and my man Greg Brown called and he says
it's the 17th round
he said you know it's in that would you
take twenty thousand dollars
I said
yeah I don't care I want to play dog I
want to play you know and then
Bam um they draft me the 20th round as
I'm pulling back into the house right so
I pull back in the house and my
brother-in-law Josh is there
Josh is there and Josh is like yo you
got drafted this and that and I'm like
dope yada yada I was like all right
great like I was already pissed
and Josh was like go inside bro enjoy it
this only happens one time
give me your keys I'm gonna move your
car I said all right cool Josh gets the
car dog has my my truck brand new truck
and he has a door open and he thought he
put the he thought he put the car in
park he actually put it in reverse so
he's like doors open
right my sister's car is like this so he
tucks a car in opens the door puts it in
reverse gets out of the car the car
backs up and he's like oh snap he goes
the door flips all the way to the other
side oh my God and goes through the gate
my sister's gate goes through the gate
so my car's just demolished and I'm
already Miserable as this whole thing is
yeah dude and I was just so miserable I
was like this is perfect I forever
remember this day just because of this
right here okay so you got drafted go to
Houston and
for those who don't know they don't know
you're a lot of I'm assuming a lot of
people don't know your story about how
you were you're almost out of the game
then you met Rob yep
and so
tell me about when you met Rob Rob is
our our hitting coach for
um those who don't know Rob and JD have
known each other for a long time and uh
so you tell tell us about when you met
Rob like how did you meet Rob so
23rd
yeah 2013. I'm on my way out I see
Houston you know they're kind of just
really not playing me pushing me off to
the side this and that
I realized I was like you know what I
gotta do something I got to make some
kind of change because this ain't it and
come across Jason Castro
and
he was chasing Castro was going off you
know for us in Houston at the time and I
said
Jason Castro's going off though this guy
this guy really couldn't hit before and
now he's like become a really really
good hitter
like I want to know who he went to this
and that so
you know have this huge breakthrough in
the video room just studying the video
myself
and watching this whole thing go down
and spent all game literally I was hurt
I had had the handmade surgery on my
hand so I spent all game in the video
rooms breaking down swings and I said I
was like dang this is
some weird my screen don't look like
this
it's like I got to make it look like
These Guys these guys are the best for a
reason why why does my swing look like
this and theirs looks like that
so ask Jason after the game I said Jay I
said who's the guy you worked with and
he told me you know Craig Wallen Brock
out in California
so I'm like give me his number grab his
phone out of his locker I said here he
goes but he's still you know he's still
in his uniform getting all stuff off you
know and he goes shoot him a text right
now tell him I'll call him
so he goes all right so we shot him a
text got his number on the car ride back
home
I called him I said listen man I want to
come out and see you
I don't know
anything but I know what Utah Jason
looks a lot more like these guys than he
used to and that's what I want
so he's like all right we'd love to have
you this and that I said great season
ended the next day I was out in
California oh immediately immediately
okay and I was out there and I spent
rented a car a part A you know Hotel
this and that stayed out there two weeks
oh wow okay worked every day with them
for two weeks and when I met Rob Rob was
like his little assistant you know he
was just flipping the balls Craig was
actually you know kind of you know the
Mastermind the teaching behind it and
the way me and Rob got tight was
Craig had a flip phone
right and Rob had an iPhone or like
Craig was living in you know in the past
and so when I went back home I was like
Hey listen this and that I'm like I'm
gonna keep doing this but I'm gonna send
you guys video this and that and Rob's
like well send it to me because Craig's
got a flip phone and I'll show it to him
I said all right cool so I would just
send the videos to Rob and then Rob
would give me you know his little
comments back
and then we kind of you know that's how
the line of communication started and
then when I was in Detroit you know
obviously I give back
I went to Venezuela I go off in
Venezuela Detroit signs me
go to Detroit go off and then right in
September I started hitting like a
little funk
and I was like damn what am I doing
wrong what am I doing different this and
that's what I sent Rob some videos
and Rob responds you know right away and
I remember I asked Rob I said hey would
you mind if you came out and like you
know like worked with me for a little
bit
and he goes nah man I love it he's
working with high school kids at this
time
and I just paid for his lesson whatever
he missed and he just came out and he
hung out for a couple days and Bam
started raking okay so then that's how I
got tight with Rob and then like in 2015
was kind of the same thing I would call
Rob whenever I was in a funk he would
come out and get me right so then I got
to the point where I was like wait a
minute every time this guy's around me
I'm raking and my numbers are good
and then when he would like when he
would be out for a while like you know
I'd be all right but they're not as good
yeah you know I was like I need to hire
this guy full time so that's how I
started working with Rob 24 7. and then
y'all became best friend yeah we became
best friends you know we're with each
other every day yeah I mean
literally literally literally and so you
come to Boston right do you uh end up
signing in Boston coming to Boston and
that's when you had met me yep and I
remember uh I don't think I I didn't
meet Rob until closer to the season I
believe but seeing uh seeing you work
seeing
your uh
mindset to hitting
was completely different like completely
different in like a lot of people you
were pretty much one of the first ones
to kind of approach hitting the way you
do approach hitting and I feel like
that's obviously been something that uh
you and Rob have really kind of mastered
it's been it's really it's really neat
to see you guys to see you guys work so
and you know you're one of 18 that has
a four Homer game yeah tell me about
that game when you uh when you uh got to
the park that day and you worked were
you did you work with Rob that day nah
tell me about that day that was the day
where like day before we're facing uh
John Gray in Colorado
and I remember I felt this like
weird thing with my shoulder I was like
I gotta be soft on my shoulder and Bam
hit a homer off John Gray
so not go back to I go back to LA and
we're playing the Dodgers
and I remember that's where Rob lives so
he brought him and his wife now Jessica
out to the game
and he's like yo so what are we working
on today I said just just watch this BP
real quick
and he goes all right
and I couldn't keep the ball in the
ballpark the whole BP for like five
rounds it was just like whack whack it
was like literally every pitch I was
hitting out it didn't matter where it
was Rob's like yeah let's ride that
today you know and I said all right so
then that was what's what I remember
coming out my first at bad and striking
out to Rich Hill on a fastball right out
of the middle I said how did I miss that
swunga missed it swung and missed right
through it was just like I had termites
in my Barrel okay I said something's up
and then I was like oh no wait I forgot
this guy's got that little ride I got to
be more like on top of them so I said
all right
I got it and then that was it and then I
just once you got it and then boom boom
boom couldn't help it yeah it just used
all you need to do is get a swing off
that's it just swing at a strike and
that was it okay that's what it felt
like it's like just kidding Paul in the
zone
um so let's go back uh a little bit back
in 18.
um do you feel like that was
the best year of your career
I would say so I mean you won two silver
Sluggers yeah I would say so
um
17 was pretty good 17 was really 17 was
really good but I think 18 was probably
just most consistent I would say um 17
hours to get really hot yep and then I
got like you know I had a couple cold
spills but my hot spills kind of
overlapped the cold ones but 18 was
probably the most fun you know getting
hanging out getting you know become
friends with you and and just the team
we had man we had such a good team with
a bunch of good really really good dudes
that was a really good team with a bunch
of really really good dudes did you
enjoy playing in Boston yeah I did
it's a tough place to play you can see
how people get worn out by it that's for
sure it's a tough let's play but
it's fun to play but it is it's fun it's
the fans are just as
you know
emotional and hard on me as I am on
myself so it's so it's you know that's
why I was able to
you know take it well I think other guys
that can't handle that aren't that hard
on themselves and that's what the guys
that maybe don't play as well yeah right
I do want to tell this story though
because that year at the end of the year
um we were both chasing some accolades
and I think it was the last month
I had you know you were my hitting coach
we had Timmy hires awesome Andy
barquette awesome
and they helped me a lot you did most of
telling me what to do and then all three
of us meet Andy and Tim would figure out
how to implement it you know what I'm
saying so you would say hey you need to
do this and then you had to go do your
work yeah and then us three figured out
so anyways
the last month of the Season you know us
three couldn't figure it out and so
I had came and hollered at you
and maybe it wasn't wasn't it may have
been may not have been it may have been
the last month though I don't remember
and you were like nah dog I'm not
helping you
I'm not helping you this this last month
I'm like what you mean you're not
helping me what are you talking about
you've been helping me for seven months
and now all of a sudden you're not gonna
do it it didn't make sense and and uh
and then this is why I I will love you
forever because you're like nah I'm
chasing this Triple Crown
I'm not helping you so I was like ah
okay got it got it and I respected it it
was good it was it became like a
friendly uh
a friendly battle which I think helped
us
yeah 100 and we were at that point where
it was like you know what
I remember like we both had our best
years of our careers
um we both were like we already clinched
the division we were up by like however
many games yep and it came down to that
final like two or three weeks yeah
really what it came down that's what it
was it was like final two or three weeks
and I knew you were in a good enough
spot you know like I I always knew like
I was like he's right there he's
throwing out one or two a game he's he's
mad because he ain't getting four yeah
right and I remember us being we're both
tied at like
I think we were hitting like 335 or
something we were just both tied at
batting average and the mookie goes and
now Brock you know remember Brock Holt
was always bringing it up Jade I
remember it Bronco JD what you gonna do
mooc what are you gonna do if y'all tied
uh batting average this and that to the
last game Mookie's like I ain't letting
him win yeah he's like I ain't letting
him win I said all right I said you know
what hey these last two weeks you on you
I'm on me yeah all right all right and
we became like a friendly competition
about it and then we go to Cleveland dog
and that's where you just went
off I was like well there goes that yeah
yeah first game you go like five for
five then you go four for five the next
day and I was like dang and I'm sitting
here and I was just so I was like so mad
because
I was actually like lining out and
hidden balls like I'm like dang that
should have been a hit dang that should
have been a hit and mook's over there
just going off and I said and I'm just
laughing and every time he would come in
he would look at me for side eyeing and
I'd be side eyeing and laughing you know
and it was just fun dude I don't know
that was just honestly like you play
this game a long time and
be in that situation that we were in
like I feel like that's something we're
always at least I will always remember
oh yeah for sure and look back at like
dog that was like we were
started off like I mean we still were
amazing teammates but we had a little
two-week competitions you know spill
right there which is fun and it but it
never got like
even though we were competing I never
wanted you to not get hit 100 I'm saying
100 right let's see who can yeah keep
going you know so that that was fun and
then
so then I end up uh we played 19
together and then I end up getting
traded in 20 you know then this four
years
I think it was what three you know three
years I'm sorry yeah that we didn't four
years that we didn't play against uh
2020 21 22 and then 23 yeah
I can't do math but anyways three years
we didn't play together but we kept in
contact contact kept talking
and then uh I remember us talking like
we got to play together again yeah and
I didn't know how it was going to happen
I think I think us just talking about it
we manifested it 100 and so
I remember
when
you had signed you called me or text me
or something you you were coming
and I didn't really think you were
actually going to
but then you had signed and you didn't I
was like wow I get to play with my boy
again I wasn't even thinking about the
baseball yeah this is just like I get to
get my boy my boy back you know what I'm
saying the baseball was going to be the
baseball right
and um man it's no irony that like
for me I'm having like another good year
and you're here yeah I'm saying and so
um it's been good how have you enjoyed
La so far it's been good man
you know like you said bro being able to
like hang out and you know
I think the one thing that makes us real
tight is we both have that
you know we get obsessed with with
hitting and obsessed with that whole
like you know that mindset of what we
got to do to hit and not taking no for
an answer and that's how we you know
became really good boys in the first
place
um and just being alongside is you know
someone else that has those same values
as me has made it like a lot more
enjoyable you know playing here in La
um you know obviously being with Rob too
is you know that's been cool has been
cool because there's another one of this
my best friend too and
you know just the boys have been great
um the city's been fun this is the
city's this has been a really good team
too as far as not even just the baseball
but just a group of guys yeah you know
no definitely has been really really
cool it's been fun you know
um
playing in La is
with that weather dude is unbelief it's
unbelievable so tell me the difference
outside of the weather because that's
the obvious the difference between like
LA and Boston
I don't know for me it's the weather man
the weather obviously I mean the obvious
stuff the baseball the baseball the
baseball not necessarily like so I'll
explain if like for me
the fans watching the game
the atmosphere
is
two completely different things for me
yeah like La is like more chill
100 you know people get to the game on
Cuban time yep you know what I'm saying
even though they're not Cuban you know a
lot of Mexicans
um
but you know what I'm saying like
they're chill and whatever and if we win
super excited if we lose they're more
like sorry we'll we'll get them tomorrow
like you guys are still good in Boston
you feel it they want to kill you they
want to kill you they're there in the
very first inning
and they're ready they're nah there is
no tomorrow you know so that's what for
me that's what it is so I want to hear
what you I mean that's well put that's
exactly how it feels
um you know just from the simple
standard the fans and everything like
that and the media is the other side of
it you know it's it's not easy it's not
an easy place to play
I loved it I thought it was great I
thought it was a fun place just because
you know the intensity of everything
but
you're right it's just you know it's
different it's that East Coast like
Fenway Northeast Yankee you know that
whole rivalry type stuff versus like the
West Coast more chill different yeah the
uh okay so now the sports cities like
Boston's a super dope sports city like
all the sports yeah and then La is
obviously a super dope sports city do
you think what would be the difference
do you think it that's that's the
difference across the across the board
as far as like the fans you know what
I'm saying or do you like because Boston
going to a Celtics game
versus going to like a Lakers game
like I love going to NBA basketball yeah
but like that's going to the Celtics
game to me is like
everything you know being in the garden
yeah and not the garden but yeah I guess
the other garden and and
feeling them on top of you and just
talking mad yeah Shish boy golly all
over you dude I never I've been to a we
went to I think we went to one Celtics
game yeah I went to one Celtics game I
went to the
the Eastern Conference Finals and uh
in Boston uh 2021 I think oh so you was
living yeah it was less I went one time
it was wow they were playing the Heat I
had to show up all right
boys all right so let me uh so you you
love not love football you play football
I want to uh play a little game with you
though all right all right
you were start let's say you're starting
a
football team yep
who's qb1
qb1
my am I going with my heart or am I
going with my brain
you got to go whatever you got to go
with I mean man it's hard to go against
tour right now no this is oh I'm sorry I
didn't even explain it so
I'm sorry you're you're using the NFL
you could roll with tour
um
but I'm talking about the Dodgers oh
you're saying the Dodgers on the Dodgers
you got the Dodgers guys all 26 or 28 of
seven of us or however many people is on
our team right now because it's
September
um but who's qb1 for you
it's 27 options how many 26 so add to 28
options I'm sorry we're going with
Kirsch Kirsch is qb1 okay maybe yeah I
like it I think I think it's great he
would manage it's a lefty so it's kind
of weird but all right
you chose Tua yeah and two was a lefty
yeah yeah yeah so you must have a thing
for lefties yeah I don't know I mean
okay
I think I have the answer for this but I
want to hear what you say
who's uh your defensive end because it's
definitely not you
my defensive end we have to we're gonna
need someone big and athletic
there's one big athletic dude on our
team
who are you thinking
you've got to say it first though I
can't make your time I'm thinking like
Bobby Miller like he's a big guy okay
all right so you're gonna go with Bobby
you're gonna say Freddy no no no no no I
would go with graterol
you think he moves quick enough to be
defensive end bro graterol is one of the
most athletic people on our team really
you don't know that nah I only see him
pitch you
for those who don't know watch him feel
the ground ball when a comebacker he
feels oh I saw that flips it up I said
oh my and he caught it throw it you
don't see him get up you don't see him
robbing your homers during BP bro he
robs like half of your homers he jumps
I'll be fighting if I saw that bro watch
when other guys hit he stands in the
track
all right we're going he just go yeah he
a big body big body he can move bro yeah
he's a big dude that can move so but you
chose Bobby no no we'll go grab her all
I love that Team bro you can't take him
all right all right all right the heck
go ahead so you chose curse I'm gonna
choose
um
I think at quarterback
I would choose me
[Laughter]
excuse me I would be like a Kyler Murray
dog I'm telling you running around all
the time football is that it my brain
works for offense I don't like I don't
watch it but like if you tell me to go
play flag
I'd have you like as a wide receiver no
yeah yeah 100 that requires me to get to
run and get hit I don't want to do all
that bro I just want to throw it I have
you like that kid um from Colorado
Hunter what's his name Travis Travis
Hunter he'd be playing both sides oh no
man and playing defense no I played
football until I was you get bored if
you didn't play defense you'd be sitting
on the sidelines be like what do I do
yeah you're right if it was flag cool
but if you tell me to put on some pads
Mookie's out and hit somebody
absolutely not okay so DN I got greater
all you got Bobby Miller wide receiver
one
I was gonna pick you okay so I'm your
wide receiver yeah okay I think for uh
my wide receiver one I would probably
go with
I think I think I will probably go with
Joe Kelly
okay
because I feel like he's fast
he's a really good athlete okay so I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go with Joe Kelly as
my uh wide receiver one what about uh
running back
ooh
this might sound a little
Connor Wong
oh no is he's Colton mom Colton Wong
sorry
[Laughter]
Wong Cole Wong is your virus yeah
Colin's fast dude he is fast he's fast
he's small he's gonna hit them holes
right gone I'm going
with
Altman
oh I got Alvin more like a linebacker
well linebacker's not optional all right
or like a full bag
full back I will go months
that's true yeah
um so I got out man I'm gonna probably
need to be a receiver it doesn't matter
whatever
and you picked
Cato Colton Wong yeah okay so what about
your kicker
oh
dang kicker
I have no idea I don't know anyone that
could
kick I mean this is probably gonna sound
super uh
I don't know if racist is the right word
Latin guy yeah you gotta go you gotta go
because he did good at soccer you know
yeah yeah I'll go with Mickey row
because Mickey loves soccer yeah I'm
gonna go you go with Mickey Rowe
um I'm gonna pick
I don't think Peralta can kick nah he's
too stiff yeah too like I don't think I
don't think he can kick so
um
I guess I can't even I mean
mm-hmm
this key K plus hacker
I have no idea he didn't even look like
he plays Iron but I don't know I guess I
gotta roll with it though because he's
Spanish
I know none of us know how to play
soccer yeah you know so okay and if
there was one and if there was one
player right now
and this is all the MLB that you could
think do you think there's one player
that
could play in the NFL right now so I
rewrote it I wrote it that wrong
I don't know probably trout you know I'm
gonna go with uh
I think trout definitely could I think a
lot of people really could
um
who would have a successful NFL career
right now
you know what judge
yeah you could see judge you could say
judge for sure he would definitely I I
think I may would go like Acuna yeah he
could do it because he can he's he's
just as fast as all of them yeah he's
Twitchy
you know because those athletes are
different 100 football athletes are are
are different yeah especially to
normal you're just yeah they just have
that physique that body you know yep
it's like more of a
this might I might get a lot of bad you
know like you know people might not like
this but I feel like football's more of
like
what God gave you oh okay yeah yeah like
that's fair versus like a skill yeah
that you really have to grind out and
work on like hitting yeah it's just
different right it's different it's just
different yeah it's like
if you're not big fast strong and you
get you get all those genes you it's a
good chance it could be a pretty good
football player yeah I mean just yeah
because there's people that don't even
play football that are big fast strong
they may not even know they're big fast
and strong and they just ask that's how
you made the football team bro you was
throwing in PP you know dropping dimes
they're right-handed tour I got a couple
questions
from uh from fans let's uh let's go to
the first question
what Dodger game has been your your
favorite this season what game has been
your favorite this season what game has
been my favorite yep
oh man I feel like they all kind of run
together it's so hard
I mean if I had to pick any I would say
any of the like you know the Padre games
that we played and those games are fun
San Diego are fun those games are fun
um
there was the the for me the game that
was probably the most fun was a
we were down
five or something and we I hit the Grand
Slam uh
it was a 3-0 where the 3-0 we were in
San Diego oh yeah 3-0 and I hit that
that was probably one of my favorite
games because we were down early and it
came all the way back I remember that I
wasn't playing that game yeah you
weren't playing that was hurt you had to
back you out of me yep yep yeah okay so
uh who uh who's your favorite F1 driver
Max verstappen he's a go right now he's
the goat yeah he's a go right now like
he used to be Lewis Hamilton for so many
years when I got into it Lewis was
number one
and I just remember saying like I can't
pick the guy that's number one yeah you
know
I gotta pick the up and comer the guy
that's trying to make a name for himself
and then I picked him
and the guy hasn't lost Doug you don't
lose right now so you need him what's
his name Max Max verstappen Max
verstappen Max
hopefully you get to see this man
got to get JD out there so we can meet
you dog in in Vegas that's what's up you
know what I'm saying hopefully hopefully
he can beat you at least I'm not really
a driver and driving guy you know you
said you're gonna come if I go this year
you said yeah yeah
and and I really want to but then the
act of sitting and watching Cars yeah
it's not like that oh what is it no
we're just sitting there and just I'm
thinking you just see me watching the
car going I'm like nah you know
socializing
a couple drinks yeah okay hanging out
vibing and they come around like oh you
look at them and they're gone
10 seconds of them going
and then they're gone the other side of
the track and then you're just hanging
out socializing and then you wait for
them to come back talking Nash you know
okay just having fun good I mean all
right we gotta wait on Max I know come
on max
um you ever played a Immaculate grid
I never played it but I heard about it
okay
um do you want to do one
if you want or do you have any do you do
you have any stories that you want to
tell
I know you say you want to address an
issue oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so you
know
I was watching one of your shows one of
these days and how you supported me yeah
yeah I was supporting you know I had to
see what I was getting myself into okay
and mooc
threw out that I was one of the cheapest
ones on the team and I said hold up
wait a minute these are facts
I need to I need to tell the world a
little story about my man Mook here
all right so there you go you know what
I'm just gonna listen
so
2018 we won the World Series
right
me and Mook just you know
we're peaking right now in the world and
we're we're on our way to Vegas
we go to Vegas and
stars align we come across we get to
gamble we get to hang out with Drake
you know where I'm going with this one
now I know where you're going with this
one yeah okay so we're hanging out with
Drake mook's got all his boys I got my
boys you know there's a full line of
you know
security guards around the table this
and that one with Drake so yeah we get
invited to like go camping with Drake
and I was like do you want to gamble
with Drake I said hell yeah
you know so
go to the table we're playing baccarat
and Drake's with two heavy rollers
mind you just to stop the story
um
I know where he's going with this I had
just signed it yeah yeah I was getting
to that okay yeah I was getting to that
part so I pull up and he's got two heavy
heavy rollers
like guys betting 300 Grand a hand
type rollers and I'm sitting there I
didn't know what I was getting myself
into we had just finished playing
paintball
I just finished playing paintball and
I'm like covered in like you know little
paintball marks they said you want to go
you got to go now I said let's ride
and get there sit down at the table
Mookie's I'm like Mook where you at he's
like I'm on my way this and that I said
all right let's go he was like in a
different car behind me so
we sit down and literally as we're
sitting down everyone's just you know
their phone's going off that mookie
signed a arbitration deal for the
highest paid arbitration deal for 27
what was it 27 mil yeah something like
that 27 million dollars it's like dang
we made it moogie made it right one year
27 mil so I'm sitting there and
I haven't reached down
I don't have that much money I came
straight from the paintball place with
me and I got about like 2500 on me or if
you're like three grand on me at the
time so I pulled it out I said you know
Color Me Up gives me some chips
and you know sitting there talking Drake
Mook comes in and mook's like hey man
congratulations everyone we're all
talking about it at the table before you
had gotten there so we were like damn
moose coming up there oh damn Luke's not
27 hey move congrats the other guys were
two huge Red Sox fans yep you know so
congratulations oh thanks man this and
that yada yada yada so we're sitting
there playing baccarat I got like
couple hundred dollar chips you know
like you know I think it was a 500 chips
whatever I'm trying to bet like Drake's
over here been like what like this yeah
a hand like 80 grand a hand these guys
are betting 300 Grand a hand it was
unnecessary my man mooc
pulls out a hundred and says Color Me Up
ask for five twenty dollar chips
I said mook
Mook I'm here on the side of the table
I'm like this I'm like
some chips take some chips
don't be embarrassing me like this yeah
here's a couple hundred dollars you
gotta at least put a couple hundred on
the hand dog okay look listen there was
no way I could keep up with them
eighty thousand three hundred thousand
yeah you can't I get it but you're
saying you came out with twenty dollar
hands though they let it back around the
table the limit the limit was like the
limit was not twenty dollars like a
thousand dollar a hand and they were
letting me play for like 500 a hand
and mookie walks in with a hundred I
said oh I don't know yeah give me some
chips listen
so that was that was
You could argue being cheap for sure
especially because I had just signed
that
but I I argued that it was just
me being smart
because there's no way I could keep up
with that you know I was I was dying man
that must have been one of the funniest
moments of my life yeah man that was a
that was that was that was a a really
good time that was really hey shout out
to you I want to give you a shout out to
um
you pay for uh team dinner twice this
year yeah you know I got called out on
uh you know not paying early on in the
year but I didn't even know I had to pay
at the time because it wasn't even asked
for me yet yeah yeah I said I don't mind
paying we kind of threw it on you yeah
you kind of just threw it on me last
minute like as we're walking in I said
damn hold up I said all right yeah you
know yeah
so though so
I'll I'll change my answer no I won't
change it you're still cheap but you got
to know what you're gonna spend it on
like before you before you like you
don't want to spend it but let me know
what I'm spending my money on yeah I'm
just like
you know my friends kind of make fun of
me back home like
JD won't you know
we walk into a store he's like man I'm
buying that shirt for four hundred
dollars yeah but
oh I'll go spend you know half a mil on
a boat like yeah not even flinching yeah
yeah no like it's just whatever you want
yeah it's Gotta you know I gotta see the
value in it yeah all right bro well
to rap I want to thank you for coming on
the show because uh you know it had it
took me six months
and I'm happy that you you know I'm glad
I made it man yeah you know and uh
I didn't realize that you know Cuban
time could last up to six months didn't
know it yeah just learned it this year
it's surreal it did it you know it's all
good I do want to tell you thank you
though
um for everything that you do for me I
think you know this but uh you mean the
world to me bro and not even just for
baseball stuff but just off the field
you know I really love you bro and I
really uh
know that you know we'll be friends for
life bro you know and so we'll always uh
we'll always make sure we stay in
contact one night and should I just see
you later on
um for those
who want to see JD
um I would advise just helping him
because you know he may not want to pay
for the tickets at F1 you know so you
want to see him anymore we'll pay for
him for F1 you're gonna pay for them
yeah no that's you know okay I love for
that well
get your binoculars JD will probably be
down you know mingling with all the
Drakes of the world because that's who
he gets to hang out with at the F1 race
and uh hopefully I'm there probably
there in Vegas you will though yeah
we'll be there so thank you guys for
joining and we'll see you guys later on
thanks guys
[Music]